time now for our defending the first
where we expose the enemies of the First
Amendment free expression and free
thought well you all know Ben Shapiro if
you don't worry-you Ben he's become one
of the nation's leading figures in the
effort to preserve free speech
especially on campus
he's also been the frequent target of
leftist who are trying to shut down his
speech what's the latest attempt I was
waiting for this okay this is a campaign
now to blame ben shapiro for inciting a
deadly terror attack on a canadian
mosque last year we welcome back to the
angle ben shapiro the editor in chief of
the daily walk wire and he looks so
unassuming and like banned i don't know
what do you weigh 150 pounds i mean
you're like 165
but i'm saying like you don't look like
all that intimidating i mean you you
write stuff and you go on TV but explain
how you are allegedly involved in
inspiring this horrible attack on a
mosque because you you you made comments
about islamic terror in the past and it
was all stitched together so there's
this evil piece of human crap who shot
up a mosque last year and this evil
piece of human crap happened to be
somebody who had seen some of my tweets
on twitter as prosecutors found now he'd
also seen tweets from people like bret
baier he's seen tweets from you he's
seen tweets from a bunch of different
people but it was I guess my account was
the one that he had viewed the most now
I have one point four million Twitter
followers so I guess the idea from the
left is that if somebody views enough of
my tweets they're inevitably going to
become a terrorist weird that I don't
have a spate of enormous terrorism
across the country thanks to my Twitter
following but of course none of this is
real
I mean when when Bernie Sanders a Bernie
Sanders supporter shot up a
congressional baseball game people on
the right did not say this was Bernie
Sanders is fall Bernie Sanders inside we
plays a crazy person yeah we play fair
and they don't care about those rules so
what their goal is and this is why we
bring you on for this series their goal
is to intimidate other conservatives
using you as an abject lesson we're
going to use you as an example don't
speak out on these issues because if you
do it we don't care we could be in
doesn't matter for its in Canada or
Australia or anywhere else we are gonna
brand you a hater we're gonna try to
stop your livelihood stop you from
making money stop you from getting
speeches that's what this is about
is it not so it's this malcontent in
Canada who's kicking up a fuss we've
seen it with the Southern Poverty Law
Center with there obscene lists of
Islamic you know what is it as lama
phobes or whatever it i'm on i think i'm
on that less ridiculous but they don't
want to shut down speech no question if
you're gonna talk about the SPLC by
their same logic they're responsible for
the attack on the Family Research
Council a few years back since the guy
who shot up the Family Research Council
was it was a follower of the SPLC and
used their apparently their their map of
hate groups as a target so all of this
is really dangerous and all of it is
leading to an attempt in the United
States by people on the far left to
imitate what we've seen in places like
Britain in places like Canada to
actually shut down dissenting points of
view if those dissenting points of view
do not meet with the politically correct
standards of the left so the fact that
I've tweeted out about the evils of
radical Islam and I cut a video talking
about the percentage of Muslims
worldwide who may believe radical things
based on polling data from the Pew
Research Center now this apparently was
enough to blame me for a terrorist
attack that has nothing to do with me
that I have obviously denounced that was
as I say committed by an evil piece of
human debris but again all of this is
nonsense generated by the left
specifically in order to shut down free
speech that's they're very Kanye West
has become a very interesting figure on
the cultural scene no doubt expressing
his love for many people but among them
most controversially is Donald Trump and
now he's gotten attacked by everybody of
comments he made about slavery being a
choice which is not obviously what he
meant but now it turns out that we're
seeing perhaps connected we don't know a
increase in support among African
Americans especially African American
men double support - I guess the figure
is now it's up to 22 percent it was 11
percent approval now it's 22 percent
where the overall approval is also
increasing I believe to 16 percent from
8 percent that's interesting is it just
a coincidence here with Kanye
you know it's impossible to tell
obviously whether it's a coincidence in
this short period of time but I will say
this what Kanye did by basically saying
think for yourself if that's such a
threat to the left it demonstrates how
the left has to use identity politics to
shut down any real debate listen I don't
think the Kanye West ought to be
nominated for head of the Heritage
Foundation round think the guy is
spending his off hours reading Frederick
Hayek but what Kanye did say here which
is very simple is listen I'm not just a
black guy and I'm not just a Hollywood
celebrity I'm an individual with my own
thoughts and feelings I get to formulate
my own logic and I also get to figure
out what I believe and if everybody else
thought like this then perhaps we ought
to be able to have these conversations
that we haven't been able to have so far
good for Kanye West for at least
beginning the conversation I'm stunned
that it's Kanye doing it but the guy
gets all the credit I mean it print is a
pretty amazing stand that he's taking at
a time when he doesn't have to take it I
just think he's trying to say to people
you don't have to be imprisoned by your
past as hard as it was as abusive and
unfair and unjust as it was it doesn't
have to define your future and a lot of
philosophers have said that over the
centuries and frankly over the millennia
you can create your own identity Hillary
Clinton was out there yesterday with a
day before yesterday a QA about
socialism America whatever let's watch
you may be the only presidential
candidate since World War two that
actually had to stand up and say I am a
capitalist and you did did it hurt you
probably I mean you know it's it's it's
hard to know but I mean if you're in the
Iowa caucuses and 41% of Democrats are
socialists or self-described socialist
and I'm asked are you a capitalist and I
say yes but with appropriate regulation
and appropriate accountability you know
that that probably gets lost and though
my gosh she's a couple less all right
Ben Mike one sentence I'm she actually
told the truth good for Hillary she
finally stumbled across something that
is true and she said it Democrats are
tending toward socialism what can you
say inadvertent but nevertheless she was
bundled up quite a bit there